ANDI GUTMANS: Hi, everyone.
I'm Andi Gutmans,
general manager
and VP of engineering for
databases at Google Cloud.
Thank you for joining us
for Google Cloud Next.
We have some exciting product
announcements to share with you
in this session.
Digital innovators
are disrupting
traditional industries in new
ways because of their ability
to use data and software to
deliver new digital customer
experiences.
Customers expect personalized
and seamless experiences
across their devices, in all
places, and at all times.
To deliver these next-generation
digital experiences,
developers need to be
empowered to build apps faster
by leveraging fully
managed databases,
use their existing
skills and investments,
and build their apps for
success with databases that
were designed to power the
most demanding workloads
in the world.
We offer best-in-class databases
for always-on applications,
with global reach
and unlimited scale.
Google Cloud is committed to
open source and open standards.
We offer managed
services that are
fully compatible with the most
popular open-source engines,
such as MySQL,
Postgres, and Redis.
We manage the complexity
of running your database
so that they are simple to
use and operate, and make
app development faster
and easier for you.
Leading organizations in
all regions and industries
have placed their
trust in our databases.
And our databases remain
one of the fastest growing
segments of Google Cloud.
In the newly
published Gartner 2021
"Scorecard" for operational
databases, Google Cloud
received an overall
score of 90 out of 100,
which is higher than the score
of the largest alternative
cloud provider.
Google Cloud met 100% of the
required criteria outlined
by Gartner.
Also, Gartner predicts
that 75% of databases
will be deployed or migrated to
a cloud platform by next year.
Imagine 40 years
of databases placed
on-premises being superseded
by cloud databases
in such a short duration.
It's amazing.
Our customers'
journey to undergo
data-driven transformation
typically involves three steps.
The first step,
migrate, is there
to help customers move
existing applications
and databases to the cloud,
frequently on a tight timeline.
Customers need a
fast-track approach
to lift and shift what they're
running today to the cloud.
This as-is migration already
adds tremendous value,
even if it doesn't
provide the full benefits
of cloud-native capabilities.
Once migrated, many
of our customers
seek to modernize their
database environments
by transitioning off
expensive legacy databases
and onto open-source databases.
For customers looking to build
next-gen applications entirely
in the cloud, they're
in the transform phase.
This is about unlocking
new possibilities
in competitive differentiation.
It's about delivering new
transformational customer
experiences and innovative
business models.
For your existing databases
that you need to easily migrate
to a fully-managed
cloud service,
we offer Cloud SQL, with
full compatibility for MySQL,
Postgres, and SQL Server.
It is one of the fastest growing
large services in Google Cloud.
Cloud SQL offers
easy integration
with existing apps and
Google Cloud Services,
like Google Kubernetes
Engine and BigQuery.
More than 650,000 GKE pods
securely connect to Cloud SQL.
And BigQuery users
query over 125 petabytes
of data in Cloud SQL
on average in a month,
using our federated
querying capabilities.
We've invested heavily
in improving Cloud SQL
and making it enterprise-ready
for your demanding workloads.
In the past 12 months, we
have introduced capabilities,
such as cross-region replicas,
point-in-time recovery,
customer-managed encryption
keys, VPC Service Controls,
and IAM support.
We have significantly improved
the maintenance experience
for customers and given
them maintenance controls.
Cloud SQL maintenance
is, on average,
80% shorter than it
was 12 months ago.
And maintenance for
My SQL and Postgres
is now shorter than that
of competing offerings
from other cloud
providers, based
on figures published in
online documentation as
of August 2021.
Earlier this year, we launched
industry-leading observability
with Cloud SQL
Insights for Postgres.
It empowers developers to
address database performance
issues themselves at
no additional cost.
This has become one
of the fastest adopted
new capabilities in Cloud
SQL, and we look forward
to delivering
equivalent functionality
across more database engines.
In addition, we recently
introduced Cloud SQL Cost
Recommenders with Active
Assist that empowers developers
to better manage costs.
We have made migrations to
Cloud SQL easier and faster
with the Database
Migration Service.
This offers a simple experience
with minimal downtime
for reliable and predictable
migrations to Cloud SQL.
It is serverless,
secure, and offered
at no additional charge.
More than 85% of all migrations
are underway in under an hour,
and a majority of customers
are migrating databases
from other clouds.
Database Migration
Service currently
supports MySQL and
Postgres databases,
with support for SQL Server
migrations coming soon.
For customers bringing Oracle
workloads to Google Cloud,
we offer our bare metal
solution for Oracle
that allows you to run Oracle
databases the same way you
do it on-premises,
but cost-effectively
and with less than 2
milliseconds latency
to all of your GCP services.
Bare metal solution
enables you to continue
using your existing Oracle
technologies, such as RAC,
Data Guard, and RMAN.
For workloads that require
microsecond latency,
we offer Memorystore.
Memorystore is fully compatible
with Redis and Memcached,
and offers an easy migration
destination for your Redis
and Memcached workloads.
Memorystore is a scalable,
secure, highly available
in-memory service that is used
by 90% of the top 100 Cloud
customers.
We recently announced a
preview of Datastream,
a serverless change data
capture and replication service.
With Datastream, you can
easily and seamlessly
deliver change data streams from
your Oracle and MySQL databases
into Google Cloud Services, such
as BigQuery, Cloud SQL, Google
Cloud Storage, and Spanner.
The serverless
architecture of Datastream
transparently scales up
or down, as data volumes
shift in real time.
Now let's discuss our
transformative databases
and how they can help you
transform your business
models and the digital
experiences for your users.
Today, your business-critical
applications
may need to serve millions
of users across the globe
and process data volumes that
are an order of magnitude
higher than just
a few years ago.
New, always-on business models
require these applications
to be reliable, secure,
and continuously available.
Your applications need to
scale seamlessly and sustain
high performance, even during
unexpected spikes in demand.
We give you access to the same
databases that power the most
demanding Google applications,
like Search, YouTube, Gmail,
Maps, and Payments.
Google had to invent
these databases
because traditional
databases were not
designed to handle
these demands for scale,
availability, and performance.
We offer not one, but three
such transformative databases--
Spanner, Bigtable,
and Firestore.
All three of them
have a common set
of highly differentiated
core attributes,
like industry-leading
five 9s availability
SLAs, no maintenance
downtime, unlimited scale,
automatic sharding,
zero-touch global replication,
automatic failover,
superior price-performance,
and enhanced security
and compliance.
Spanner is our fully
managed relational database
that offers the
familiarity and developer
experience of a
relational database
and the scalability
of a NoSQL database.
Spanner enables unlimited
scale, so you can easily
accommodate future growth
without painful architecting,
adjust your capacity on-the-fly,
and pay for only what you use.
It allows you to deliver
high-performance transactions
with strong consistency
across regions and continents,
so you can simplify
operations and place data
close to your users.
Our enterprise customers in
financial services, gaming,
retail, technology, and
many other industries
run some of their most
demanding operational workloads
on Spanner.
With Spanner, you
can spend less time
worrying about how to
scale your database
and instead focus on
scaling your business.
As wonderful and
unique as Spanner is,
it wasn't the most accessible
database for developers.
We wanted developers to be able
to start small with Spanner
so they could design their
applications for success
from the get-go.
To this end, we
recently introduced
more granular instance
sizing for Spanner
to democratize access to it.
With more granular
instance sizing,
you can start at 1/10 the
cost of regular instances,
equating to approximately
$65 per month.
This means you can
start small and easily
scale your Spanner instance
as your workload grows,
with no downtime.
Developers love the scale
and availability of Spanner,
but they wanted to take
advantage of Spanner
using their familiar open tools
and their existing skill set.
Therefore, to continue this
theme of democratizing access
to Spanner, we're
excited to announce
the preview of a Postgres
interface for Spanner,
starting today.
This empowers developers
to take advantage
of Google's transformative
relational database
using standard tools and skills
from the popular Postgres
ecosystem.
This interface combines
the power and reliability
of Spanner with the familiarity
and portability of Postgres
to enhance flexibility.
By providing a
Postgres interface,
we're democratizing access
to Spanner for millions
of developers and ISVs.
Starting today, you can
create Spanner databases that
use PostgreSQL
dialect and connect
with its OpenWire protocol.
This interface supports
Spanner's rich feature
set using most popular Postgres
data types and SQL features.
Postgres interface
for Spanner is
available at no
additional charge.
What this means is that for
your Postgres workloads,
we offer you not one, but
two fully managed services.
For maximum compatibility
with open-source Postgres
and for the easiest
lift-and-shift migrations,
you have Cloud SQL for Postgres.
For your most
demanding workloads
where you need unlimited scale
and five 9s availability SLAs,
we offer Spanner with its
new Postgres interface
that allows you to leverage
your skills and investments
in the Postgres ecosystem.
We're super excited about
our rich Postgres offerings.
Now for apps that require
consistent single-digit
millisecond latencies and need
to support millions of requests
per second, we offer Bigtable.
Bigtable is our fully
managed NoSQL database
for large operational
and analytical workloads.
And it's HBase-compatible.
Bigtable is uniquely capable
at powering use cases
like personalization at
scale and fraud detection.
We're excited to share that
autoscaling is coming soon
to Bigtable.
This will allow Bigtable to
automatically add or remove
capacity in response to changing
demands of your workloads,
so you'll only pay for
the capacity you need.
We talked about the
importance of the velocity
of your application iteration.
For rapid app
development, we offer
Firestore, our fully
managed scalable
serverless document database.
Firestore is beloved
by developers because
of its ability to serve
both as a document database
and a backend as a service.
Firestore enables
offline support
with real-time synchronization.
An example of how
much developers
love Firestore is
that Firestore has
more than 250,000 monthly
active developers and Firestore
apps power more than 750
million monthly active users
using Firebase authentication.
Not only is Firestore
extremely developer-friendly,
but we're also focusing
on making Firestore
more enterprise-friendly.
We're introducing a
number of enhancements
to Firestore for greater
enterprise readiness.
With that, I'd like to introduce
one of our most innovative
customers who has
successfully accomplished
a data-driven cloud
transformation.
It is my pleasure to invite
Kumar Menon, SVP of data fabric
and decision science
technology at Equifax.
Kumar, thank you for
joining us today.
We would love to hear
about Equifax's innovation
that you and your team have been
driving in partnership with us.
KUMAR MENON: Thank you, Andi.
I wanted to start off by giving
you some background on Equifax
and the transformation
we are under.
Equifax is a leading data
analytics and technology
company and is one of the three
biggest credit rating agencies.
We are present in 24
countries worldwide.
In 2018, we embarked on
a massive company-wide
transformation to
modernize our technology.
This was a result of an
unfortunate breach incident
in 2017, which brought
the global spotlight
onto our company.
Due to the oversight that
was placed on us and the need
for us to ensure we are good
custodians of the high-fidelity
data we have, we realized
that patching and modifying
our legacy systems would not
be a sustainable solution.
We made the bold decision to
adopt a cloud-first strategy
and rewrite all of
our data platforms
and associated
applications, leveraging
cloud-native architecture.
Our legacy systems
were operating
in silos, which made it
difficult to effectively
innovate and monetize
our differentiated data
assets through new
multi-data products.
So we also took this
as an opportunity
to reorganize our data under a
common enterprise domain model,
onto a single
global data fabric,
with the security and
automated governance baked
into the architecture.
The goal was to make it easier
for our data and analytics
and product teams to
innovate and deliver
new products
faster, thus helping
our customers and consumers
make better decisions.
Here's what our end-to-end
data flow looks like.
The data fabric is at the heart
of the Equifax value chain.
If you look at this
illustration from left to right,
the data fabric helps us ingest
different domains of data
we bring into our ecosystem
in a consistent, reliable,
highly-performant, governed,
compliant, and secure manner,
so that our product, data and
analytics, and business teams
can leverage the synergies
of all the data assets
to innovate and deliver products
that our customers need.
In short, we want global
data at our fingertips.
Equifax Cloud will enable our
product innovation, growth,
and competitiveness.
The data fabric platform is
pivotal to the Equifax business
model going forward.
Why is the Equifax data
fabric a gamechanger?
Let me give you a few examples.
Equifax has moved from
80-plus data silos,
enabling multiple
sources of data
to be standardized and organized
into a seamless data fabric
with logical separation
in governing groups.
The structure drastically
simplifies our architecture
and gives Equifax the
ability to act quickly
to address customer,
regulatory, and security needs.
We will achieve bolt-on
mergers and acquisitions
with better and faster
integrations than ever before,
accelerating our
growth tremendously.
Now let's look at a more
technical view of the data
fabric and see how we have
leveraged GCP-managed database
services to deliver our
analytics and operational
workloads.
Let me break those down
for you from top to bottom.
The data fabric
services shown here
help curate the
raw data we collect
across the various domains, such
as credit, employment, wealth,
utilities, et cetera,
to name a few.
We then key and
link the data, which
is a form of entity
resolution process
that helps us identify a single
unique instance of an entity--
for example, a unique
consumer identity--
across all the domains
of data we collect.
This data is then made
available for predictive models
and real-time decisioning as a
set of purpose-specific views
with the regulatory
rules applied,
thus ensuring permissible use.
This low-latency,
high-value ecosystem
leverages Cloud BigTable
as the core Datastore
and the pipelines are
built in Cloud Dataflow.
The Cloud BigTable
scalable architecture
and its support for
customer-managed encryption
keys help us provide a
resilient, reliable, and secure
data platform to support highly
stringent millisecond SLAs
that our customers
demand from us.
The data fabric
is tightly coupled
with our Ignite and our
analytics services, which
is used by our data scientists
for feature engineering
and building predictive
models, which
can be deployed into
our decisioning systems,
facilitating a full
ML ops ecosystem.
The data lake that powers
Ignite is built on BigQuery.
Our enterprise catalog services
are built on Cloud SQL.
This is what you see in
the middle of this picture.
It houses all of the metadata
for our data features
and models, plus the rules
that are applied on our data.
This provides the auditability
and the automated governance
capability.
This design gives Equifax
a leading position
as a data analytics
and technology company
in a highly regulated space.
Finally, I wanted to leave
you with some metrics of where
we will be when we are finally
migrated onto this platform.
You're looking at 75-plus
data fabric services deployed
in seven regions supporting
the 24 countries we operate in.
We would have 10 billion-plus
of observations keyed,
using almost 90,000-plus
clicking and linking rules,
enabling us to manage 800
million-plus unique identities
globally.
We are well into our journey
with significant production
traffic coming soon.
We have an aggressive
plan to grow
the company via acquisitions
and organically.
The partnership
we've had with Google
through this entire
journey has been great.
Both our engineering
teams have been
able to collaborate
closely to achieve
these capabilities and
the seamless access
to the product engineering
teams at Google have been key.
We have invested in a long-term
relationship with Google
and look forward to a
symbiotic partnership.
Thank you for having
me, and hope you
guys found this
presentation useful.
ANDI GUTMANS: Kumar,
thank you for sharing
your story of data-driven
cloud transformation.
It's truly inspiring.
We look forward to our
ongoing partnership
with you and Equifax.
At heart, Google
is a data company.
When it comes to
managing data, we
have to solve some of the
most difficult problems.
We re-imagined
databases and invented
Spanner, a database
that gives you
the best of relational and
nonrelational databases.
Our databases benefit from
disaggregated computing storage
and our privately-owned
global network
to improve performance,
scalability, security,
and availability.
What all this means is that when
you adopt our Cloud databases,
you immediately benefit from
our longstanding culture
of engineering excellence
and innovation.
There is a lot more
exciting content
waiting for you in
the upcoming sessions.
I invite you to join these
sessions to learn more
about Google Cloud databases.
And I would like to
thank you for joining us
at Google Cloud Next.
We hope to partner
with you to accelerate
your data-driven
business transformation.
Thank you.